يبدو انا شعبيتها الرئيس باراكا اوباما
ولجو الديمقراطيين له لتعزيز حدود حملاتهم
ادت الغرض منها وفقا التقارير متعدده فان
الديمقراطيه نستنجدوا بالرئيس الاسبق
باراك اوباما للحيلوله دون خسارتهم وفقا
لنيويورك نيوز ويك طبعا نقلا عن كبير
الاستراتيجيين السياسيين السابقين لاوباما
فان توقيت حملته كان صحيحا واستطاع عبرها
ايقاف زحف الموجه الحمراء للجمهوريين
وحرمانهم من تحقيق مكاسب اكبر اااه ديفيد
اكس لورد الذي شغل منصب كبير
الاستراتيجيين والمستشارين اليوم في
تغريده له ان الرئيس السابق قام بحمله من
اجل الديمقراطيين في الولايات المتاحه
عندما كان نخبونا مترددين وقال اكسلورد ان
اوباما سعد حز وعلى التمسك بالسلطه وهو
يتحدث عن المرشحين الديمقراطيين ويمزقه
خصومهم الجمهوريين كانت استطلاعات الراي
على مدار منتصف العام الجاري تشير الى ان
الديمقراطيين يواجهونه رياحا سياسيا
معاكسه قويه بسبب التضخم وعدم شعبيه
الرئيس جو بايدن لكن ربما لا يزال ليحظى
بشعبيه لدى الديمقراطيين منذ تركه لمنصبه
عام 2017 انعكس ذلك على المرشحين في
جورجيا
وويستنسن وبنسيرفينيا وايضا
[موسيقى]